today we're making the world's spinniest
ping pong table and for that we need 150
table tennis rubbers which we're going
to spread onto the surface at the end of
this video stay tuned we're going to try
the world's most impossible serve edge
bounce to edge bounce let's see how many
tries it takes
[Applause]
after this we know what's the likelihood
of making this shot in a tournament you
ready for the serve emma
oh that was like no
oh 10 centimeters 300 tries maybe
so close
maybe in the top five hardest things
we've done
it wasn't even close
chocolate break
let's try
speaking of chocolate we're gonna make
the world's largest table tennis racquet
made completely out of chocolate if we
reach 5 million subscribers by the end
of the year make sure to subscribe so we
can make this happen
[Music]
[Music]
there we have it so that took us one and
a half hours about 1 000 attempts not
the easiest serve
choose your color i'll take the pink one
can you get spin with it yes you can
actually that one
no i differ as the ball is gonna go
and we should be afraid of jackpots
i have a good idea
it didn't work but it was a good idea
next challenge is
this
that's quite good it actually works
[Applause]
no
oh
[Applause]
probably my best roller ever
[Music]
on the wrong side of the table
sure that i lost the point
came on my side yeah this was a fun
setup we're still missing the rubber
table so make sure you watch until the
end
like this
come and play against me ml against you
foreign
[Music]
take a quick water break sure
yeah
good to stay hydrated
[Music]
i think we did a good job so we invented
a new shot the behind the back snake
[Music]
good snake
144 rubbers to cover a table tennis
table the spin is going to be crazy
[Music]
watch out i'm giving you a side spin
[Applause]
it's easy to give around the net spots
it's gonna be fun
i think we should fill the whole table
[Music]
oh yeah alex check out our table that's
a lot of robbers don't forget to
subscribe guys the moment we have all
been waiting for we are going to play on
the world's spinniest tables
that's a good one
that was good
that's why it's called the world's
spinniest table we're gonna go and find
someone to challenge us on this table
so we have yokka here hi everybody yoka
are you ready to try out a new table of
course zero zero zero
oops yoki actually has the blue rubber
only one lost with the blue rubber maybe
this is the second one
[Applause]
i'm 65 but still quite fast
nice return
what's out boy yoke is destroying me
[Music]
let's try a chop
i think i'm going to like the chopping
oh
that's the right one i'm gonna continue
from that
okay
when we reach 5 million subscribers it
will be the world's biggest chocolate
pink on the racket make sure to
subscribe